these things are very practical
questions that depend on continuous
models but we have to be really careful
this is part of what we're going to
unpack today and in the next week or so
because while continuous random
variables share a lot in common with
discrete random variables they're
clearly not the same and importantly
some of the techniques and strategies
that we use to discrete random variables
they do not work with continuous random
variables and I want to give you a
couple of examples of that number one
like we said before the continuous
random variable you can put in a any
value like you can put in in this case
twelve and a half but that doesn't make
any sense in this situation you can't
have twelve and a half coins facing
upwards right you can only have twelve
or thirteen I keep saying this to try
and emphasize to you that discrete data
and continuous data do you behave
differently even when they're describing
the same situation and I said to you
that the strategies or the tools that we
have we discrete random variables
they're parallel but they don't always
work neatly with continuous random
variables so to give you an example of
that I want us to return practically to
this word as discrete random variables
and I'd like you to think about a simple
situation which is if we were to roll
two dice okay now if we were rolling two
dice and then we were adding up the the
sums we were finding the sum of the two
up facing faces then pretty predictably
I think we could all come up with this
this is a this is the sample space right
it's a two-way kind of like diagram a
table that shows all of the
possibilities and what's great about
this is it shows which ones happen more
frequently and which happens less
frequently right so if I took these
outcomes and I just you know drew them
into a chart it would look something
like this do you agree with that right
some of the outcomes like two are far
less common because you have to have a 1
and a 1 there's only one way for that to
happen and other outcomes are much more
frequent you know 6 7 & 8 there's lots
of combinations of dice that will give
you that outcome so that's why on the
chart they are higher now wonderfully if
you remember what this kind of chart is
called again there's a lot of words in
this topic that you really need to wrap
your head around this is a relative
frequency histogram okay and we got
quite used to
using these relative frequency
histograms to answer questions about
probability right let me give you an
example okay
can you use this table to answer the
question what's the probability that I'm
going to roll a 5 that my variable which
in this case is the sum of the two dice
what will be the chance that it's a 5
now I think we all know we can look at
the relative frequency histogram or we
can say oh just look at the relevant
column right now that goes up to 4 and
36 you simplify that to 1 over 9 no
problem I can answer that just look at
that individual column but now if we
think about what happens we've brought
it out how do I consider multiple values
and again with discrete random variables
this is not hard right from 4 to 7 we're
saying 4 5 6 & 7 they're all fair game
they're all possibilities or outcomes
that I'm interested in so to work out
the probability all I have to do is look
at all of those individual probabilities
and Adam are right it's not complicated
so in this case 3 over 36 plus 4 over 36
plus 5 over 36 plus 6 over 36 or
whatever that happens to equal which by
the look at it is 18 over 36 so half I
guess that's going to give you the
probability all right one last one just
for the sake of it what about the
probability from 2 to 12 3 to 12
everything about this one so this is all
the probabilities right this is
everything all together so if I were to
out of The probe's without any
calculation I know this is the whole
thing so it's clearly going to be equal
to 1 or 100% okay now I heard that you
know sort of is stuff that you remember
but I want you to see why those ideas
are parallel but slightly problematic
when you try and apply them to
continuous random variables okay let's
suppose for example what we wanted to
represent was the distribution of
heights in this classroom okay now first
question why is that a continuous random
variable answer height is something that
you measure it's not something you count
right you know you could be anywhere
between say you know 160 centimeters 170
centimeters it's not like you can only
be 161 or only 162 you can take any
value in between so this is what we Mew
I there's a continuum so it's a
continuous
random variable okay now one of the
things that marks a continuous random
variable if you have a look at the graph
of it and I'm just making this graph up
okay but I think it's you know a
reasonably accurate one it's gonna be a
smooth curve right
I've got probabilities here and they're
not going to be in nice neat blocks like
we saw with the dice this curve here
represents all the different
probabilities of one height or another
okay now this curve here because it is a
curve and it represents probability it
gets a different name we don't call this
a histogram we call this guy a
probability density functions so the
denser the probability is the higher it
is you know the higher the graph is okay
now I said to you before that when
you're using continuous random variables
the tools from discrete random variables
don't all work neatly and I can give you
a very simple example of why that's a
problem you remember I asked you before
what's the probability of rolling a 5
and you just looked at the bar on the
chart you're like oh it's equal to that
and then off you go okay but if I ask
you a parallel question but for this you
know hi it's right we run into problems
really quickly right for example suppose
I ask you what's the probability of
selecting someone in class who has a
height of 178 centimeters okay
now you might wonder why did I randomly
choose that number and the answer is
it's because I'm a bit self-centered and
178 centimeters is my height okay now
the reason why this is problematic is
let's just think about this for a second
right suppose I said okay there's like
roughly 20 people in the room so you
know one out of twenty is bad 0.05 okay
if I said the probability of picking
that height is 0.05 the first problem
with that is my height is not exactly a
hundred and seventy eight centimeters
maybe it's a hundred seventy eight point
one or one hundred seventy seven point
nine I actually don't even know because
I just measure and I remember to the
nearest centimeter okay so number one my
value may not actually be 0.05 but even
if it wasn't that suppose there was
something low like everyone 0 1 or 0.001
no matter how low it is because you've
got this continuous function here right
there's an infinite number of other
possible Heights right so if the
probability of my height was
point zero one let's call 178 then what
would be the probability of 170 0.1 and
then probability 170 0.2 if they were
all you know 0.01 and you added them all
up then you're going to go over what you
have in fact an infinite series of these
and because there's so many of them even
if they're all you know adding up to a
small thing they could add up to
something more than one and that's a big
problem
we know probabilities can't do that so
this is not a good way to think about a
continuous random variable in fact the
only way you can talk about a single
value is that it's individual
probabilities zero so this is no good I
don't like that it's not very helpful
way to think about it even if it is
technically accurate so what's our
solution okay
there was a long journey that
mathematicians took to try and arrive at
a solution to this paradox but I'm gonna
sort of cut to the chase so that we can
start working with these things the
solution for how to address this problem
is to not think about individual values
in a continuous random variable but to
think about intervals on a continuous
random variable if we think about the
probability of not just your height
being this but your hive being between
two values right like say 170 and 180
this completely solves our problem
because what we can do is we can assign
any kind of value that's relevant to our
data we might say are the probability of
being 150 160 in our cost is 4 percent
and the probability of being in the next
class up 160 270 that might be 17% and
when you add all of those up because
I've got four separate chunks right
there's not an infinite number of them I
can add all of these up and I get 100%
or or one right which I know is what
probabilities are supposed to do so this
is kind of a bit topsy-turvy right
earlier we were saying discrete data if
it's large enough often looks continuous
so you can model it in a continuous way
but to deal with continuous data often
the best way to actually handler is to
break it into discrete chunks and I kind
of think that's why this topic is called
random variables we're going to focus on
continuous random variables but you kind
of can't easily separate the screen and
continuous
they're kind of to helpful lenses to
look at the same kinds of realities you
just have to be careful which lens
you're using okay so you can see here
like we say we solve the problem
everything adds up to one there's just
one catch if you want to be able to do
this and calculate the probabilities of
these intervals right these classes and
what you need is the ability to work out
not just the area under a nicely
rectangular bar type like the histograms
we've seen before what you need is to be
able to work out the area underneath
your probability density function even
when you're probably density function is
this weird unusual curvy kind of you
know object if only we had some kind of
level of maths or area of maths that
allowed us to work out areas under
curves and probably your start you can
now connect what's going on here in your
brain but before we get to that and I
promise you know if the gears are
turning I will we will reward that
concept connecting in your brain I'm
getting ahead of myself I want to stop
talking and let you guys have get a
handle on this practically so I want you
to think about this example scenario
here okay it's a continuous random
variable and I want you to have it got
these questions right firstly I want to
have a look and think why is this a
continuous random variable and not a
discrete random variable can you tell me
have a think okay look it takes some
take a moment to you know dissect what's
going on what is it that's being
measured here this is this is x right
this is the variable and so because it's
a measured variable not a counted
variable that's what makes this a
continuous random variable okay so
that's how our in this situation I'm
secondly can you see why vadhana has
been working up into classes it's what I
was showing you before in that graph
right we need to have separate sections
or intervals so we can work out the
probabilities of each and we're going to
do frequency and work out relative
frequency by dividing by the total
number of things so we have frequency
relative to the size of the whole group
okay so this stuff is revision I'm gonna
let you guys have a go at that and then
we will come back together when you've
made a bit of progress and we will try
and answer some questions
that are really to do with continuous
random variables in a continuous away
okay so off you go see how far you can
get